breaking has fast after a 141 day hunger
strike hisham abu hawesh expects to be a
free man by the end of february after
the israeli military agreed not to renew
his detention
the deal was reached after talks between
palestinian and israeli officials
gaza's armed factions were threatening
an escalation if abu hawash died
this extended battle in which every
palestinian mobilized and used all his
tools was a successful strong and
influential battle
through them and through our national
unity and cohesion around the prisoners
and their issues we affirmed that we can
achieve victory
the 40 year old father of five was first
arrested on october of 2020 and was
subject to israel's policy of
administrative detention which allows
palestinians to be held indefinitely
without charges
palestinian human rights organizations
say israel has issued 1
600 administrative detention orders last
year there has been an increase in the
use of hunger strike as a way to combat
this policy
60 palestinian prisoners have underwent
hunger strike in the year 2021 the
majority of them were facing
administrative detention and all have
been able to reach a deal to set a
deadline to their administrative
detention palestinians organized social
media campaigns to highlight the
prisoners issue some started hunger
strikes in solidarity and others took to
the streets in the occupied west bank
the gaza strip and lebanon they want an
end to the israeli detentions
we think that's obviously the fact that
it's being resolved is a good thing we
have as a matter of principle always uh
spoke
been very clear in saying that people
who are detained
should be tried charged and tried in
accordance with due process or released
and that has been our our position on
administrative detention the palestinian
prisoners club says 500 prisoners in
israeli jails including four minors are
held without charges
some of them have been imprisoned for 15
years
avohawesh is expected to return to his
family next month
but the practice of detention without
charges is far from over
ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied west
bank